hello everyone and yes we are returning
to the coverage of the feeder grand prix
and we are starting with a game that you
guys have requested the most and as
usual for good reasons it's lavon ariana
versus andreas pinko i i have to sorry i
have to increase the font size of
lavon's name i keep it a little bit uh
a lowercase because the duda i was
playing against magnus and duda has uh
well young [ __ ] has too many letters to
fit um
you know
properly so i have to make it smaller uh
but yeah uh just so you guys don't uh
there we go i don't again have some ocd
issues uh it is levon aaron versus
andreas penco and the really awesome
thing about this game is that um yes
pengo thought that he was playing
against hikaru today and that he had the
the white pieces or rather this is
yesterday's game uh but he was preparing
the wine pieces for hikaru and he gets
to play lavon with the black pieces so
it will definitely have um a different
effect
than you might have imagined uh so let's
uh let's check it out uh levon with the
white pieces opens with d4 we have
knight to f6 c4 e6 knight to f3 and d5
the queen's gambit declined is on the
board uh knight to c3 and the bishop to
b4 spanko goes for the ira goes in
defense very solid setup
e3 and now we have castles we have
bishop to d2 and b6 now preparing to
think it to the light square bishop here
so bishop to d3 uh sorry uh before
bishop to d3 we have c captures on the
e5 e captures and now bishop to d3 we
have bishop to b7 and now queen to c2 by
lavon uh castles is the by far the most
popular move here alabon has something
else planned as well you know that live
on very very rarely castles we have
rooked e8 and now a3 challenging this
dark square bishop
uh asking do you want to capture on c3
or do you want to go back maybe to d6 or
to e7 uh a spankle goes all the way back
to f8 and levon now plays a move that
has not been played until now uh but
knight bishop to f8 is also uh
it's only been played like uh maybe once
or twice uh here castles is a known move
uh but levon prefers not the castle he
plays knight to g5 and it is now as of
movie 11 that we have a completely new
game so you can see that lavone is
putting all of the pressure on that king
side you uh of course um i have to
imagine h4h5 is coming it's lavon who's
playing and he's probably not castling
kingside and now how do you defend this
the problem is if you play something
like h6 which seems like a good idea and
it usually is here it's just made into
just a bishop h7 check and now it
doesn't matter what you play if you
capture then queen captures with
checkmate and of course if you move the
king then knight to f7 is checkmate uh
so after knight g5 g6 is played of
course now we prevent the bishop from
ever capturing that h7 pawn but now
levon continues with h4
again h5 will will definitely be on the
board uh we have c5 by esipenko and now
h5 and here uh the problem is you can't
really go for this pawn if knight
captures we're we're just gonna play
knight captures on h7 that rook captures
on h5 first knight captures on h7 first
and now after king captures g4 and
black's entire position just falls apart
so you have to be incredibly careful
here
and you have to play
a move that you really don't want to
play in a situation like this you have
to play bishop to g7 and it's still not
all that great for black for example h
captures we're going to play f captures
and g6 d captures in c5 and after b
captures we're still going to capture on
h7 and after knight captures we're going
to play bishop captures on g6 attack the
knight attack the rook here and once you
play something let's say knight f8 you
you'd rather you know give up
the exchange than than a full piece
bishop capture 78 queen captures and now
queen side castles and there's just no
way black will will save this in a in a
practical game the king is wide open yes
you do have two pieces for a rook but
still this is
it would be very hard however it is the
the best um yes bingo has and with with
absolute perfect play you can you can
play this uh but after h5 is panko
played h6 and now uh the entire position
just falls apart so uh feel free to
pause the video here and win the game
for lavon uh while i give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on playing the
absolute strongest winning move in a
classical game and this is only move 13
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show of course the movie is h
captures on g6 we give up the knight and
we completely shatter black's defenses
is panko captured on g5 g captures an f7
with check king captures and bishop the
g6 check now we have king to e7 and now
queen to f5 you could also start with e4
but queen to f5 followed by e4 also
works and here black is just out of any
good options uh if you try some like
queen d7 you offer a queen trader we
just capture on g5 next rook to h7 is
coming the knight is of course pinned
and there's just no good move here for
black so instead after queen to f5
bishop the g7 is played now but now
comes e4 and it seems like you shouldn't
be able to play this because black is
controlling this three times uh the
problem is if black captures it then we
play bishop captures on g5 and whatever
black plays doesn't really matter let's
say c captures on d4 we just capture
here and after captures rook h7 check
kink to d6 and now look at this knight
b5 check king the c6 and the rook the c1
checkmate so this is only one of the
many possibilities that uh could happen
if if this was played so after e4 you
can't really capture the e4 pawn knight
the c6 is played and now uh what do you
play here well uh bishop captures an e8
uh we have queen captures an e8 and
queen capture 78 is uh uh the the the
well not the greatest way to go uh but
yes pink was also very low on time even
though this is a classical game he was
extremely low on time which we will show
even have a nice photo of the
of the um uh handshake in the end uh but
here uh king captures ani8 was the
absolute best thing to do now you you're
welcome to check this out for yourself i
just need a second to let meadow in in
the room
yeah i mean i asked him if he wanted to
to go uh with me upstairs uh when i went
to record but he was like nah and then
you know just in
mid recording he just wants to go in but
yeah here king captures would be the
best because after let's say bishop
captures and g5 you could still find
some counter play with queen to d7 you
offer a queen trade and now okay let's
say bishop captures queen captures on f5
e captures on f5 bishop captures an f6
knight captures and e5 threatening the
bishop also knight the c7 check a
beautiful fork is here uh and the best
black has is just bishop captures on d4
after knight to c7 check let's say king
of seven and we're gonna capture here
captures captures now queenside castles
and you get this position where levon
would have two rooks uh but uh uh
ispinko would have a bishop pair in the
knight however levon is also up two
points it's five points against three so
white would be much much better here uh
maybe through some brilliant brilliant
uh
uh maneuvering spinkle could hold this
but it would be very hard
but instead after bishop capture 78 he
played queen capture 78 and here you
completely just fall apart knight
captures and d5 with check knight
captures and now bishop captures and g5
we have king to d6 if you if you go back
with knight to f6 it doesn't really help
just captures captures and rook to h7
trick
king to d8 we're going to play queen
captures on f6 and now after king sage
just queen f5 and that's it if king goes
here you deliver a check and then either
checkmate or uh well you you have to
start giving away pieces with some silly
moves like queen here
or after king to d8 you would get d
captures on c5 and now rook to d1 will
end the game so after bishop captures
and g5 would check king to d6 was played
and here just queen captures on d5 came
to c7 and now rook to h7 and he was in
this position on the move 23 that
andreas pinko resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
in a in a grand prix event 23 moves in a
classical game uh that's simply
incredible and levon played this really
brilliantly uh in his style keeping the
king in the center of the board the king
never moved from the e1 square he just
started pushing his h pawn we all know
this is lavon's signature move and uh
well you've seen how difficult it was to
defend there were a couple of
possibilities like uh
the one that we've discussed here with
bishop to g7 but after h6 the position
just completely falls apart and i
promised you a photo of the uh of the
event i think this is the one yeah this
is the one so uh
here for your viewing pleasure uh we can
also show that sorry i have to i haven't
prepared it so i just have to
make it a little bit smaller for you to
see i wish there was a quicker way to do
this or rather i wish i knew what the
quicker way to do this was uh but yeah
there you have it a handshake is being
offered here we can even enlarge it a
little bit you can see this pango has
only nine minutes left on the clock so
he pretty much spent his entire time uh
and uh well for a 23 move game uh that's
definitely uh definitely saying
something uh so yeah that's the game i
hope you guys enjoyed it and this very
nice photo uh if you have any of your
own favorites of course use the hashtag
suggestion yesterday the uh the grand
prix is continuing uh the leaders are
currently of defeated grand prix are
lavon ariana and hikaru nakamura they
are the only two players on three points
and interestingly they only lost their
games to each other so levon lost one
game to hikaru and hikar lost one game
to aruna
but yeah that's the game i really hope
you guys enjoyed it for those of you who
are wondering how ding is doing ding has
played already three classical games now
and he has won all three so he is also
on his way to reaching that candidates
tournament because he already is
qualified he just needs that one little
criteria of having enough classical
games to actually play the event uh so
yeah once again hope you guys enjoyed
this i would like to thank a symbolic
donation from subscriber david kimura
mehmed zomes open c smokey doula and
tyler rachiko for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the video
grand prix until it ends uh so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent start of your week